i'm Gary Stevenson
former trader andpeople's economist
this is Garys Economics and
today we're going to talk about tax...
okay so today i'm going to talk about one of the
most common questions i get on the channel which
is okay you want to tax rich people well if you
tax them they're just going to leave okay so um
this is relatively easy to deal with but before i
just take that question on i want to talk a little
bit about the fact that in a sense it's progress
we're even talking about this because when i first
started talking about tax what i would often get
back is you can't tax rich people rich people are
the lifeblood of the economy it's very important
for the economy that don't tax rich people
i think it's becoming increasingly obvious to
people that what is happening with the economy
now is not working um the vast majority of
people want something done about inequality
but it goes this question of
well maybe you can't tax them
um i think it's a sign of progress that
people have accepted now we should text them
that moves us on to this question of well can you
tax them and if you tax them are they going to
just leave basically so this idea that if you tax
rich people they will leave is actually based on
a misunderstanding essentially of what rich
people are so i think we have this kind of
conception that rich people are just sort of
really talented amazing guys who have massive
massive bank accounts or massive bags of cash
which means if you raise taxes on them they can
take their money to another country they can take
this big bag of cash and they can just leave but
this is not actually what rich people are um and
i explained this a lot in my video what is wealth
rich people are rich not just because they've got
a lot of money often they do have a lot of money
the main thing they have which makes them rich is
that they own assets um in this country the U.K.
but also in most rich countries that's largely
property so we're talking about buildings
this could be flats and houses people live
in or it could be the mortgage you haveon
your flat that you live in but also commercial
property so they'll own skyscrapers they'll own
the shops and the restaurants they'll own the
buildings they'll own the shopping centres
they'll also own the land the farmland they own
the natural resources so you know if you see those
windmills that generate electricity or we've got
offshore oil rigs here in this country they'll
own all of these things the natural resources the
buildings the land and every single time you use
one of those things so every time you live in
a house or a flat every time you go to work in
an office every time you shop in a shopping centre
every time you eat food that was grown on the land
you pay money to these rich people it's very
important understand this rich people are rich
because they own the assets that that we need
to live and once you understand this you realise
that this idea that the rich will just leave is a
little it's a little bit ridiculous right because
if the rich people leave and the reason they're
rich is because they own all of our assets well
the assets are still here and we can still choose
to tax those assets if we choose to um i think
the best example of this and um perhaps the only
positive thing to have come out of this ridiculous
Russian-Ukraine war is that finally governments
decided that we're going to tax some rich people
specifically in this case Russian oligarchs and
very famously they went after Roman Abramovich
and Roman Abramovich he he tried to leave but
the problem is like he can't put Chelsea football
club in a bag and take it with him and this is the
fundamental problem of rich people rich people are
not these people are not magic you know these guys
are not gandalf the wizard they don't just have
richness like in their blood they're
rich because they own our assets
and even if they leave the assets are still
here um and we can choose to tax those assets
so at the moment we live largely in a tax system
where we essentially allow rich people to choose
where they live and to pay tax on all of their
assets where they live but we don't need to do
that right if a rich person flees the country to
try and avoid tax but they still own for example
your mortgage or your house or the office you work
in the government can choose to tax those assets
and you might say well what if they sell those
assets well to be honest i think in a sense that's
what we want right we want you to be able to
own the house that you live in without having to
owe a massive mortgage to rich people we want you
to be able to own part of the commercial property
in the country and the corporations in this
country you know at the moment these rich people
they own your country they own your mortgage they
own your house right and even if they leave they
will still own your country your mortgage on
your house and your country can choose to tax
them on assets so so really it's very very simple
it's a question of do you want your country to be
owned by people who pay tax or not and if you
do then it doesn't matter where they go because
it's it's your country and you can ask the people
who own your country to pay tax on those assets so
um i think it's it's very very simple really and
i think it all comes down to this you know Roman
Abramovich was not able to put Chelsea football
club in a bag you know and these rich people no
matter where they go this country will still exist
and the assets will still exist and they can be
taxed here and um i think when you understand it
like that you realise it's actually very simple
of course we can tax them and that raises the
question well why don't we then and um you know
there are a lot of possible reasons why that
could be but i'm going to give you a couple
suggested reasons number one rishi sonic is
the 222nd richest man in the country he's
worth over 700 million pounds his father-in-law
is one of the richest men in the entire world
and he chooses the tax laws um the previous prime
minister David Cameron made 10 million pounds
within a year of leaving office and he made
the tax laws Tony Blair i think he's worth
about 100 million pounds and he made the tax
laws so we are putting the tax law decisions
entirely in their hands of people who are
multi-millionaires or maybe even billionaires
and then they're telling us we'd love to
raise tax on rich people but unfortunately
it's just totally impossible and um unfortunately
some people are believing it um don't believe it
because um we can tax them it's in our power and
we can do it all we need is to um come together
come together and all agree that that's what
we're gonna do so um yeah support the channel
tell your friends tell your family if we want to
tax them we can and we really should thank you